so I'm Samuel and I've been working for
nearly four years at octo technology as
a data scientist mainly in the industry
field so octo is a consulting company
based in Paris so I saw that some people
from the New York Times are part of the
attendance and I'm here to answer one of
the Christian here how to build AI we
can trust so I'm drinking of course I
don't have an answer to this one but
more seriously I'm convinced that in
order to trust our models we first need
to know how confident they are in the
own predictions so what do I mean by
that well let's start with a little game
so imagine that you have some money and
you're a data scientist which things we
can happen at the same time you want to
invest that cash into some product
hoping for some return so you first
reflex here is to build a super tuned
machine learning or learning model and
absorb bunch of analysis you your is
stating between two products a and B and
your model gives you the price
expectation for example over one year so
what product do you investing here
please raise your hand if you choose
model a okay and choose male B well
right okay B seems also the right option
to me since as we will make more more
profit or according to this place well
only if we consider the mean expectation
indeed if I include the uncertainty in
my decision-making process do you still
make the same decision
well maybe not depends if you're gambler
for gambler you may go for B but
personally now I go for a so my point
here is exactly that making decision
based on data is hard but if we were a
bit more disciplined about quantifying
the uncertainty we might make better
decision okay
so a person is I started thinking about
it when I saw this tweet from Eric Brown
Hudson New Year's resolution every flood
I make during 2018 with contain
uncertainty estimates so I thought this
guy is definitely right and life to do
this as well and that's why I've been
working on this topic trying to find
some pragmatics technique that allows to
get insight about uncertainty in machine
learning model so I try to share some
some insight with you today and we'll
start with a journey for random forests
and also for that we will dive will into
an example pragmatic example to
illustrate the construction of
prediction intervals so I took the
critical temperature for
superconductivity forecasting data set
and according to Wikipedia
no matter is a to be superconductor if
it has a critical temperature below
which the resistance dropped a briefly
to zero okay the goal here is to predict
for a given superconductor material the
minimal temperature from which to become
superconducting so the target variable Y
here is in Kelvin so let's start with
some quick reminder how to build the
decision tree for regression
the idea is to recursively create splits
by minimizing loss loss function for
example the mean square R and a binary
split is defined like we can see a
variable here it's N or X and a
threshold 2 and the predicted value in
each leaf is the mean of the sample that
fall inside okay so to find the optimal
splits which are eight overall features
we iterate over all splits so that's a
pretty algorithm and the best the best
split is the one that minimizes the mean
square error in the left leaf
plus the mean square error in the in the
right leaf so this is done until a leaf
is pure so
pure leaf means that one observation
there is only one observation or several
that have the same target value so we
can't split it anymore okay so now you
will be a forest with with those trees
so the first of tree is built by using
the badging techniques and badging
stands for bootstrap aggregating so we
build a lot of decision trees 1 2 etc
and 1000 by bootstrapping so it's
basically you're you're making something
with replacement on your data and then
you agree gate all those constructed
richly honors by averaging the
projections and it gives you an estimate
and if you take the mean square roots
the conditional mean okay okay now one
day I was reading one of my favorite
blog here data down the day to dive and
when I came over this news three
sentences so one can use a random forest
as from Tai regression rest by expanding
the tree fully then a prediction written
individual response variables from which
the distribution can be built if the
forest a large enough and the nice thing
is that this intervals can be first very
dated okay so there are three main
takeaways here first of Redd's large
enough is an estimate of the conditional
distribution second prediction intervals
can be first very dated and third each
tree has to be fully expanded so let's
do it
and this code here shows how to train a
random forest with well-known
scikit-learn library and we will build
the prediction matrix on our
superconductivity data set okay so the
chosen criterion is beautiful the mean
square or to estimate the the
conditional mean
then we need as we as we told before we
need many trees to estimate the
prediction the predicted distribution in
jobs and to minus one is just to
paralyze that paralyzed the constriction
of the trees and myths and beliefs equal
to one is to indicate that we expanded
risk until the leaves are pure so there
is a confirmation list here so we
iterate over each observation from the
test set then we iterate over each trees
from our forest and we basically make
our prediction okay and that's how the
result looks like here for row zero you
have the prediction of your thousand
trees okay so let's let's take a look at
this matrix for example for prediction
for for the world zero of this material
and we see that every tree gives close
pretty prediction okay the model seems
to be pretty confident here so the the
mean 38 value is 2 point 5 and the next
predicted value is like five point four
therefore the Bryan's feels higher on
row four here predictions vary from 30
to 80 for Calvin so the random forest
doesn't seems to be so sure about itself
on this sample right so a visualization
of the density function will help us
understand the repetition of those
predicted temperatures so I like this
violent plot scenes from the Seabourn
library since it gives us a good idea of
the distribution I'm here on the x-axis
it tells us which material we are
looking at 0 1 2 3 and the y axis is
around taken by the predicted critical
temperature in Kelvin the violins are
the distribution so this is quite
different than a single point as we can
see and we will try to interpret each
conditional distribution here so
observation zero and one seems to be
robust prediction since violin are wide
and the model is confident here okay
observation to know is not so robust but
it has some extreme value as showed the
tail in a temperatures and the
observations three is really uncertain
all trees have different prediction
Ryan's is very high okay
so if we just make a random phrase here
we have four point and with the
technique I show you we have all the
this distribution that gives us a lot
more information right so let's take a
step let's take a step back now sorry
I'm not sure it means that there are
true no I don't know I don't know maybe
some information about the underlying
data I don't know so let's take a step
back here and observe results for 100
materials and as will not see anything
with hundred of a violin
we only plot the 90% prediction
intervals and Booth are built by taking
percentiles 5 5 and percentile 95 induce
predictions on this distribution sorry
yeah ok
and the result looks now like this once
again x-axis it we find materials so 100
materials sorted by increasing round
truth and y-axis is a certain pressure
on cabin so now try try to remember
point to it is possible to press very
date the intervals so this simply means
the here that we can count how many
interval contains the
truth for example this one contained the
ground truth the salient point and this
one does not okay
and the number if we come over 100
intervals there is 91 Pradesh ground
truth that are into these intervals and
guess what this is right since we have
built 90% prediction intervals so we are
very lucky here
so now let's focus on another
interesting things if you look carefully
predicted intervals for high jump
I critical temperature seems to be
bigger then deuce for low temperatures
so the mean height of intervals is quite
different as you can see here why is
that it's a bit related to to to your
question maybe because I don't know
maybe some of you have any idea of why
the model is more uncertain in high
temperatures yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
that's that's the the reason so Creek
critical temperatures are in Kelvin and
there are Minot by zero so now if we
look at the distribution of the target
variable in the training data we see
that it's exponentially decreasing again
with a spike and the Gucci model
I don't know white lot in experts until
it filled and yeah
so the model had way more data for low
critical temperatures to learn it's not
surprising that it's more confident in
this region okay in fact the the
uncertainty in general is the sum of two
different concept
so it's either due to a lack of data in
certain region or a limitation of the
model this is called epistemic
uncertainty and it is the one we can
reduce like here in a temperature we
maybe need more data or we need to have
a
a better model or whatever or it can
also be a real and irreducible viability
and this one is called aleatory
uncertainty for example when you flip a
coin you you can't read it what will
raise it right so let's take a little
point three now we say before that each
leaf must be pure but what if we don't
grow the tree is fully so this is a
fully expanded tree each leaves are pure
and there are two cases here we have
live with a unit sample and here as I
told you previously there is a leaf with
two samples that have the same critical
temperature so we completed any more so
it was like fifteen point six and the
two sample have this critical
temperature now in comparison this is a
pruned tree and we have stopped making
splits when the next leaves will have
had less than 600 sample inside
okay so parameter a means sample leaf is
600 now each prediction is now the mean
of the training target value that felt
inside the leaf okay so here it's a mean
of the 618 target value hence by having
only means the Ryans of our 1,000
predictions for all tree has decreased
so it looks like this when we look at
the density plot for up for one sample
the distribution of predictions that
look previously like the blue curve with
a big violence is now with mean sample
leaf equal to 600 the orange curve and
with a really diminished variance okay
and by putting the same figure as before
we observe that only 40 out of 100
intervals now contains the ground truth
so this is not 90 percent prediction
intervals anymore but there is something
so solution is to keep all the training
values in memory in each leaf if we do
this we can actually reconstruct all
distribution from the training dataset
so the sacred garden package here
implement this and we can now build
frontal regression forests with print
trees
okay so we'll illustrate what happened
in this package say we have a first of
two frill tree t1 and t2 with several
prediction that fits inside with
different target value and if we do as
before the distribution would be
composed only by two means here Y read
and write blue okay instead of this we
keep in memory each training target
value with their associated weights and
we use here like this and we use the
weighted percentile method to find the
prediction intervals and this basically
allows us to recover all the versions
from the training data okay so I told
you about safety Jordan package and
that's how we implement the prediction
intervals basically the same interface
as sake if done and then you make your
Nenshi person prediction intervals right
again with min sample if equal to 600
okay oh okay so far we've seen how to
get uncertainty by building prediction
interval with random phrase but I guess
not everybody here use random forest so
I was myself happy when I discovered
this but I asked myself how can we
generalize these to other machine
learning algorithms right so one can use
a custom loss function to fit the
parameters okay
containers allows us to fit a model that
estimates the conditional
alpha at one time so we'll see how it
works let's get an intuition here this
is not a symmetric loss it will penalize
more the data if you go or if your
prediction is about the ground floors or
below so imagine we are fetching a model
we try to find the
that minimize all this function with a
decent gradient or some optimization
algorithm so here the example is with
alpha equal to 0.1 so we should estimate
the 10th person type right we'll see
that the absolute error is not penalized
the same way for a predicting value
above or below the branches
let's take y1 equal to 7 Kelvin and our
prediction with random parameter
randomly initialized parameter is equal
to 12 Kelvin so the error is minus 5 and
on the graph minus 5 gives us a penalty
of 4.5 so it does come from here look at
the formula our prediction is above the
ground truth okay so we penalized the
absolute error by 1 minus alpha so 0.9
okay so point 9 multiplied by 5 is 4
point 5 another example now our
prediction is below the error is plus 5
and it brings us to 0.5 and if we look
at the formula when we're below when the
prediction is below the ground truth we
multiplied the absolute value by 0.1 so
we have a penalty that is a lower okay
so this allows us to to to estimate
quantile alpha that just be oil that's
creating the 90% prediction intervals
can be costly since with this technique
we need to train two models right one
for the 5th percentile and one for the
95th percentile so for example if you're
training neural network you can wait
forever to Train you both your two
models here is some example of algorithm
that implements directly this loss so
you have the gradient boosting
race or from safety down you've got that
so the mobile web it's an online
learning algorithm like GBM
it's another boosting algorithm also
exhibits for the exhibits user and the
the last one is the content list that we
defined in Python for example for
Curacao terms of Law user framework that
does not implement this chrome tyler's
we'll need to create our function and
eject inject it as a callback
it's a often doable okay so here is the
implementation an example with light GBM
so we define alpha equal to 0.95 and we
read Freddy will make three models one
for the condition and min one for the
fifth percentile and one for the 95th
percentile okay now we we fit those
model and our data and we get those
results again we can cross validates it
and check that ng roughly ninety
intervals contains ground truth and this
is another visualization of those
intervals because whenever you have a
thousand of points you will not see
anything with that so we use this in
practice okay finally I put it for this
part the prediction intervals sorted by
increasing size and also the difference
between one truth and prediction as you
can see in blue and we observe that the
bigger the intervals
the bigger the error is okay and if we
compute the Pearson correlation
coefficient it gives us a 0.53 so it's
quite a strong correlation and it
confirms us that whenever our model is
uncertain so the intervals are big it is
more likely to make bigger error okay so
once again this is great but
I can keep as myself like we can
continue and wonder what can be done if
were on the classification for them
right so now it becomes a bit funny
let me finish with an introduction to
the calibration of probabilities and we
will first see two example where a good
probability estimates are needed so
first one is in marketing to evaluate
which client brings more money
we usually compute the customer lifetime
value and it can be done by multiplying
the price of a product say two hundred
dollars umbrella by the probability that
the client will bout it say zero point
one so we have a CLV of $20 here so we
need the the this probability because
they give 300 ad that you love yeah okay
then we need a good estimate like a
probability that that have a physical
meaning here and in medicine there are
really sensitive results so the
probability of having a disease for
example and also a probability with
physical meaning is mandatory so in
frequency terms we want our likelihood
to be the same as the chance of
belonging to a class what does it mean
for example in binary classification so
0 or 1 if we take our sample that are
predicted between point 39 and point 41
here so wait way to Wi-Fi etc we want
the proportion of zeus samples to belong
to class 1 to be near 0.4 here with the
binary classification we basic we can
just take the mean of all these
observation so it means if we're in this
case that there is really approach if
person person chance that they belong to
class 1 okay
so the probability 0.39 0.42 one really
has a physical meaning here
in real life III told you that because
in real life the method called predict
robot that we all use not every day but
almost often returns bad for the [ __ ]
is due to the abstraction of of this
method so it carries a name that don't
reflect the real behavior of it like we
will see after and this leads to
calibration issues so first there is a
way to visualize the calibration called
the calibration curve it is basically
like this one and the scikit-learn
implements it also so you split the axis
0 1 the x axis in several bins you
select the observation that have
predictive probability inside those bins
you compute the proportion of
observation that's really belong to +1
in each bin and if the classifier is
calibrated the proportion must be equal
to the predicted probabilities so it
should follow a straight line like the
red one here okay so let's do it once
again here the calibration curve
visualization is implemented in safety
and it outputs this and in this example
we we look at the probabilities of a
logistic regression so it has been
fitted a simulated data and by
assumption a logistic regression output
real probabilities so as we can see this
classifier is well calibrated ok and
below you can find a histogram that
shows the distribution of those
probabilities on the same data the naive
Bayes output really bad calibrated
probabilities and maybe some of you have
an idea why this is due to the fact that
I'm sneaky and I have assimilated data
with three redundant feature so it
completely breaks the assumption of
Independence needed for this classifier
right so all predictions
in the Instagram below here are very
close to zero and one okay so for a
prediction near 0.9 there is only of a
60% chance to belong to class 1 and this
is the sum the symptom of an
overconfident model here okay now
another example so the contrary super
vector machine
it also outputs uncalibrated
probabilities it actually outputs a
normalized distance to the decision
boundary I told you the pretty proper
method is just an abstraction
it doesn't always output probabilities
right so this has nothing to do rosário
probability and all prediction in the
histogram below are close to 0.5 and for
prediction close to 0.6 there is almost
a 100 percent chance to belong to class
1 sorry so this is a symptom of an under
confident model here ok so there are
several solution to calibrate the
probabilities and one of them is known
as isotonic recreation I will not go
into detail for this one since I run out
of time but it's basically a
minimization of the least square with a
monotonicity constraint ok so as a when
other ok tell I let this as an exercise
for you to know why it was so you take
the bad probabilities as X variable and
associated run truth as the target and
you feed the isotonic regression and it
gives you the right calibrator ok so now
by computing the isotonic regression
with the classifier the the bad
calibrated classifier we find well
calibrated
probabilities the orange curve yeah is a
composition of nays base and the
isotonic regression so this is possible
for every bad calibrated classifier and
just know that you need lots of labeled
data
since you have to fit two models here on
different sets of observations okay okay
so I'll conclude with two takeaways if
you train a regresar compute tradition
in Tellez if you train a classifier
check if through probabilities are
calibrated or not and calibrate show
probability if it's not the case
and just remember uncertainty is not
everything and so it really depends and
how well is your classifier so how we
can predict the probability so for
example if you if you have data that
have lot of signals all your
this will be a near zero and one because
yo class failure will be able to to to
find the right answer and if I add a
simulated data that are really really
tough to to find in correlation with
with the target it would have more it
would have been more near zero zero
point five it's linked with the you know
the area Tori uncertainty here how much
you make signal into how much signal
driving into your in your data yes I
don't know this package but did you try
to cross validate the intervals or like
what what do you mean by you didn't have
any matter in much states okay okay so I
can only advise you to try to make some
regression with contain low so and and
compare it so thank you for having me
here
[Applause]